moment in infinity war tom moment in
infinity war thank you
the moment in infinity war were you
where you died I read on the internet
that you ad libbed it true or not
well what's happening it is kind of true
but really all I say is I don't want to
go I don't want to go I don't want to go
three times in a row so it's not that
amazing of an ad-lib you know it totally
works
I'm so cold I don't want to go sunlight
grandma that was the outtakes you go
when you see the outtakes it's pretty
funny it's pretty funny I just got a
note here since on Facebook live
everybody's talking about Tom's
Instagram message today what did you do
what was it I don't know what you're
talking about
I'm I don't you're an Instagram how old
are you 18 I'm not I'm 17
oh well that's why okay all right yeah
no I just go set the new scripts forever
but I might do this summer and I might
have accidentally revealed the title of
the movie
what
then can you give it to us here hang on
I forgot what is cooled hang on I forgot
what my movies called it's cool
far from home coming spider-man far from
there's gonna be a scene where he's
gonna go I want to go home I'm Way
excited for the second spider-man movie
because I've heard and I don't know you
can't confirm in but I've heard
that it might be Mysterio as the villain
that's one of my favorite villains of
all time did you read the whole thing
from top to bottom when you sit down to
read do you do it in one sitting and you
break it up and do other things well I
can't read so I have Macky read it for
me he makes me do urban book on tape for
him if you could have any one of the
other spider-man villains in the Marvel
Universe with you what one would you
choose great question man who would be
there you only know like two villains
maybe venom whoa hey everybody it's
Charlie if you guys didn't know there
was a big Avengers panel over the
weekend they talked about infinity war
Avengers for the spider-man sequel
obviously that's why I included that
clip at the beginning of this just
because they were having fun with that
but also over the weekend Kevin Feige
was talking about phase four Young
Avengers as well as what's going on with
the spider-man sequel because like Tom
Holland here talks about Mysterio Kevin
Smith is like I heard that Jake
Gyllenhaal might be Mysterio and of
course Tom Horne can't say anything but
separately like on the other side of the
United States Kevin Feige was being
asked about this during a round of
interviews so if you're finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get all the Marvel videos we're just
getting ramped up for San Diego
comic-con so way more of this kind of
stuff is going to be dropping still
doing that infinity war blu-ray giveaway
all you have to do to enter
to be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video I'll be sure to name a
winner at the end of this you all
probably saw the teaser video that I did
for spider-man far from home over the
weekend Tom Holland revealed it and made
it look like he was accidentally
spoiling it but obviously it was a very
planned PR event like we want to tell
everybody so we just let Tom Holland
pretend to spoil it so it'll be funny
but of course there was all kinds of
speculation about what the title meant
then Kevin Feige was separately asked
about it during these ant-man the wasp
interviews the quote that he gave
actually explains what some of the plot
is now obviously he couldn't confirm
that Mysterio was going to be Jake
Gyllenhaal he said that they're still
closing that deal but in that answer
lets us know yes they are trying to get
Jake Gyllenhaal the lawyers are just
trying to finish the legal work this is
actually what it looks like when actors
sign Hollywood contracts The Rock put
this out a little while ago these are a
couple different copies of the same
contract for a movie that he's making
obviously not connected to spider-man
but just an example of how much
paperwork actors and producers have to
sign when they make big movies like this
for hundreds of millions of dollars I'm
just gonna read Kevin Feige whose quote
here when he talks about the plot so
this is me quoting him well when does
that movie take place we know that it's
in the summer
I think it's summer vacation I think
he's going to Europe with his friends I
don't know what summer I mean I do know
but you don't Kevin Feige he's just
joking about the timeline like well he's
supposed to be dead but he's coming back
next summer and we all know that he's
coming back from the snap sure so even
though he acknowledges all the weirdness
in how they're trying not to spoil
Avengers 4 because we know that Black
Panthers coming back spider-man's coming
back pretty much most of the people that
were turned to ashes were coming back he
still tries to acknowledge that they'll
be promoting this spider-man movie in
the most ambiguous way possible because
Sony technically will be the people
dropping all the trailers and doing all
that kind of stuff
Marvel is just making the movie usually
people that make movies don't always
make the trailer usually that some
separate marketing group and like the
director might get input into what they
put in the trailer or the producers
might say you know include certain shots
or don't include certain things Kevin
Feige will probably be supervising some
of this stuff but part of the reason why
they made this big reveal right now
right after infinity war before they'd
ever started promoting Avengers 4 is
because they're gonna be filming the
sequel next month so you're gonna see
Tom Holland running
in the new version of his spider-man
costume now obviously because it picks
up minutes after Avengers 4 he'll still
have the iron spider costume so wouldn't
be surprised is there's a little bit of
transition time where you see him
changing between a couple different
suits because right now the only ones
that he has are the iron spider suit in
the stark tech suit that he's wearing
underneath the iron spider suit but
hopefully that explains the premise for
how he ends up traveling all over the
world he goes on summer vacation and
then arguably the villain plot drives
him to go into other places around the
world but like we talked about how Sony
has access to a list Avengers in their
spider-man movies because of the sharing
arrangement which Avenger would they put
in it if it's not gonna be Iron Man
Doctor Strange would probably be the
best person if you're gonna be hopping
all over the globe really convenient
fast travel for the narrative like okay
we need to go to this other country boom
open a portal we're there in seconds the
only other way to do that right now
would be to get Thor with Stormbreaker
opening up the Bifrost so that you can
travel instantly but that's a little
more conspicuous the thing about the
venom crossover that he's talking about
in this video too is probably more
speculation on his part they probably
told him the producers what you're
allowed to talk about if you want to
talk about venom you're allowed to talk
about it in this way it just seems like
based on all the rumors and the
behind-the-scenes stuff that they put
that on the other side of the planet
because he's gonna be in Europe during
his movie after infinity war in venom is
gonna be in San Francisco in a
relatively ambiguous part of the
timeline so we don't know what year it
is but it's sometime close to present
day and it's just an easy way to explain
why spider-man isn't swinging around
fighting venom at every turn because
he's in a completely different state in
spider-man just came back from the dead
so he's on his summer vacation before he
goes back to school in the fall my hope
is is the people at Marvel and the
people at Sony are using the venom movie
as a proof of concept for that character
like let's make sure that we do a really
awesome job with this and it's
financially successful then we can talk
about doing a more legit spider-man
crossover for those of you asking about
a Captain Marvel trailer - Kevin Phi he
also said it'd probably be a couple more
months because they finished shooting in
about two weeks so just don't expect
captain marvel footage before October
like October November is around the time
we got our first infinity war teaser
that's about the time we'll probably get
the first Captain Marvel teaser he also
said that we get that Avengers 4 title
reveal just after we get the Captain
Marvel teaser so all happening later
this year in the next couple of months
but Kevin Feige did confirm that after
Avengers 4 is revealed that they will be
way more open about their phase 4 plans
so what will happen is as later this
week I'll do another video about Young
Avengers phase 4 phase 5 things that
Kevin Feige has confirmed like yeah
we're definitely building up towards
this but they have to get through
Avengers 4 before they can make all
these announcements congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner venom Kotetsu
please private message me so I can get
your contact details while you wait for
everything click here for that funny
spider-man teaser and click here for my
Luke Cage season 2 review thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]